many of you of course I am sure watched
the Super Bowl and the Kansas City
Chiefs defeated the San Francisco 49ers
31 to 20 it was really looking okay for
the Niners there for a little while
until things just imploded effectively
the game was played in Miami Florida
of course the San Francisco 49ers from
San Francisco California the Kansas City
Chiefs from Kansas City Missouri and
Donald Trump making a mistake that lots
of little kids often make presidents
less often make this mistake and the
mistake is thinking that the Kansas City
being referred to is Kansas City Kansas
when it is of course not it is Kansas
City Missouri Donald Trump tweeting last
night before a quick deletion quote
congratulations to the Kansas City
Chiefs on a great game and a fantastic
comeback under immense pressure you
represented the great state of Kansas
and in fact the entire USA so very well
our capital C country is all caps proud
of you someone must have very quickly
told Donald Trump its Kansas City
Missouri sir not Kansas City Kansas
Trump deleted the tweet posted another
one mentioning Missouri instead of
Kansas now there is a Kansas City in
Kansas and it's right on the border
actually with Kansas City Missouri the
one in Kansas is small population is
about 150,000 Kansas City Missouri is
much bigger nearly half a million I've
been there very interesting my
impression without passing any judgment
was that the Missouri Kansas City is
more interesting I I don't know I
enjoyed myself more in the Missouri side
now almost exclusively when people talk
about Kansas City they are talking about
the larger of the two Kansas City
Missouri now maybe we're being too tough
on Trump I mean you know when I moved to
the United States and was five I at that
point didn't know that when someone says
Kansas City they mean Kansas City
Missouri it took me a while as an
immigrant when I was like maybe eight
years old maybe even nine I then learned
when people say Kansas City in general
they mean Kansas City Missouri unless
they specify that they're talking about
Kansas so I don't know Trump's just a 73
year old America
president maybe we're expecting a little
too much from him someone had a
hilarious post about this on our
subreddit a user named moving wallpaper
posted what is so painful about this is
the amount of people replying defending
this mix-up they'll say well the San
Francisco 49ers they play in Santa
Clarita Kansas City is in both states
and we are both happy or the Giants play
in New Jersey in not New York imagine
getting on an airplane destined for
Canada only to have your pilot say
whoops Ontario I thought you meant
Ontario California
now imagine that airplane being your
entire country well said and indeed I
saw comments online well saying stuff
like you know a lot of that Kansas City
Missouri metro area includes parts of
Kansas so it's not really wrong people
in that region of Kansas are certainly
fans of the Kansas City Chiefs if I said
congratulations to the Boston Celtics we
are so proud of the state of New
Hampshire would you say you know David
you're kind of right I mean the Boston
metro does include parts of New
Hampshire no he's an embarrassment on
the big things and he's an embarrassment
on the small things this is one of the
small things but it's still an
embarrassment I know that the David
Pakman show audience is full of curious
and creative people who love learning
new things and bettering themselves and
that's why I'm so excited to tell you
about one of our sponsors Skillshare the
vibrant online learning community that
offers thousands of classes on almost
any topic you can imagine and you'll get
full access to the entire library of
classes for two entire months free when
you go to david pakman.com slash skill
all of the classes are taught by experts
in their fields they've got classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design bookkeeping marketing
personal productivity doesn't even
scratch the surface I recently took a
class about photography if anybody
follows me on Instagram you know that my
photography skills leave much to be
desired and it was great I got so much
out of it and hopefully you will see the
fruits of me taking that class reflected
in my Instagram pictures sooner than
later they have classes forever
skill level whether you're wanting to
get better at something you already have
experience with you want to learn
something totally new to you you set
your own pace classes are usually less
than an hour long they're divided up
into bite-size segments so you can
easily fit them into your schedule make
2020 a year where you explore new skills
deep in existing passions get lost in
creativity Skillshare really makes it
easier than ever Skillshare memberships
are less than ten bucks a month and that
gives you access to the thousands of
classes they offer but everybody in the
David Pakman show audience gets a
Skillshare membership totally free for
two whole months just go to david
pakman.com slash skill that's david
pakman.com slash s ki ll